[Music]
John I mean if if we look to the Past
for examples of socialism you know what
which bits of those past would you
identify with today I mean we do for
example to pick up on one of David's
challenges advocate the common ownership
of the means of production and
distribution in exchange is that is that
what's socially what are the foundations
of your socialism well I think all from
the past
I think the well I think we learn from
the past and we draw from ideas of the
past but we also know we also draw from
newer ideas you know we draw from the
you know I have changed my politics in
since 2015 where because I have
encountered large numbers of young
people who come with fresh ideas with
different ways of working you know who
are much greener you know much more
interesting you know the the the way
that they will in fact in recent weeks
the way that kids at school have changed
our understanding of the importance of
climate change okay politics you know
even had an effect on like I have no
problem with that I want you to divide
it but I think that David's discourse
which was actually about in his view to
fundamentalisms
and I you know I I that that isn't a
picture of the world as it has been you
know the truth is that you know things
like you know planning I'm not you know
the state have always played a we played
an important role we do not live in a
fundamentalist capitalist world at all
you know the British state created
markets now it could it conquered a
large part of the world in order to
benefit the market it's great that was
the action of the state the state still
today you know intervenes and if you
read Mariana matchick Artaud's book
about in other that what the the state
has how the state has bit has created
many of the elements of the iPhone and
and don't forgive me what where is
socialism in this well I the way I see
socialism what socialism for me is make
it is a is and which would require a
fundamental change in the way that
society operates and the economy
operates is a society in which decisions
are made for the benefit of people and
not for profit that's what that's how I
feel and I I didn't disagree with
anything that Angela said about the
nature of Perficient you see the the
talking about the past and the failures
of the Soviet Union you know is is
that's David baggage you know he grew up
on the comes I would I've never been in
the Communist Party I've never been a
Trotsky
all right I'm arguing the differences
not by the end I would yes debates from
1917 or from the gap between the first
international and the second
international really isn't very relevant
to politics today any young people
understand it but yeah if you look at
Bernie Sanders in the states where it's
much harder to conjure up support for
for the concept of socialism he
nevertheless uses that word he probably
uses it more so there's a Casio cortes
probably closer to the generation which
Bernie that's true but you know the
reason I didn't join the greens was
because you know III the the greens
it seems to me do not in general there
are some exceptions have an
understanding of class inequality you
know the first time you've mentioned the
work class well okay I know that's an
important word to you but you see you
know you you seem to have used to be a
mass associate your whole analytical
framework is unchanged from your Marxist
though we're still trying to practical
politics we're trying to determine what
your analytical framework is apart from
not liking the present and I'm still
finding it quite high when these young
people come to you and say you know
please show us the socialist path what
do you tell them
well what what I tells have a big
discussion in a big tent
unless thing you can have everything you
know we're not please what if we
actually achieved was a massive growth
in the support for for a socialist
program that Jeremy was outlining in the
leadership election we trebled the size
of the membership of the Labor Party
we have the biggest party in Western
Europe the biggest left party in
yesterday in working in Europe so you
nearly said yesterday okay so so you if
you're outlining or we've heard from
Angela that it goes back to the economic
basis of our society is that that we've
been in fact most of those young people
who have grown up in a world where they
were told that that fundamental
free-market capitalism was the only
option
it was and yet you're leaving University
with the equivalent of mortgages and no
hope of owning a house or even renting a
complete and we've seen a matter they
they know they are going to have in
securing employment they are going to
you know they they are faced with unpaid
interns you know what our contracts and
apprenticeships while the the
beneficiaries of the global economy are
living beyond the reach of tax authority
we have seen this massive transfer of
wealth upwards I don't think anyone's
arguing about that what we arguing what
we're still trying to understand its how
you would bring about a transformation
and the transformation tool by electing
a Labour government that's committed to
attractor transformative policy for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you